and my argument for thinking about
making contact with other life forms is
we have to have an understanding of what
we are and what we're looking for before
we design the technology capable of
making contact einstein unified space
and time right in his conception of
gravity and what he was able to predict
from that was this thing called
gravitational waves ripples in the
fabric of space-time if you didn't
invent a concept of space-time you would
never fathom these things could exist
and it took a hundred years for us to
build an interferometer which is a very
sensitive instrument um they can detect
vibrations of a proton on the scale of
you know like a fraction of a proton and
um in
2015 i think it was or 17 i always get
it mixed up we actually detected a black
hole merger that happened in our
universe now that black hole merger was
an event that happened 1.4 billion years
ago in the history of our universe
because it was 14.4 billion light years
away
and those ripples have been propagating
across our universe for 1.4 billion
years